are you doing i'm going to share
something with you that might just blow
your mind simple questions that you can
ask
for people who are in university
and the professors and academics there
and then they push this story about the
origins of the human race with the
self-replicating cell from there the
different strands of fish different
strands of monkeys apes and then you
have jon jones and the whole human race
i mean this is uh
very interesting when you ask now some i
guess share this with me i'm sharing it
with you and we cover a lot more
so make sure you're tuning in when the
show comes out but the the piece i
wanted to share with you the questions
you can ask is what's the evidence for
an abiogenesis what's the evidence that
life came from non-life was evidence for
one self-replicating cell there's no
evidence
so again well-crafted well-funded story
you might as be well be telling the
santa claus story so tune in so you
don't get misled lost in confusion
with these topics of the new religion of
scientist evolution we'll be talking
this on this week's episode make sure
you tune in